Rockhead [__] we got our first killer
in the new series here and this killer
is Albert - now this [__] we're
starting us off with this [__] because
he is just batshit crazy he is doomed
like basically before even birth this
[__] it's just [__] nuts now I know
you're looking at him you're looking at
this bag and you seen that mustache do
you think it's a guy like didn't they
know this guy's a killer like he wears
like a bowler cap with a mustache well
actually things started way before the
mustache but we could mean girl mustache
and that's what that's where the problem
lies like hail and we when you're too
young to have a mustache they can't tell
you know I can't tell that you're crazy
anyway so we're gonna start this off
with a little with a little intro here
okay so the guy's real name is Hamilton
you know he's an American serial killer
so he's just some of these nicknames for
this [__] okay he was known as the gray
man the Brooklyn vampire the werewolf of
wisteria the moon maniac and even the
boogeyman okay now this [__] he only he
not only was a killer he was also a
child rapist on top of that he eats [__]
you know his famous phrase is that he
had children in every state and no one
knows that that means he ate them a rape
them but that just kind of [__] up
okay we only really got tried for a
three murders book well we'll get that
later but anyway so let's let's explain
how this law [__] respond okay now this
[__] was first spawned in Washington DC
you know his father named him after a
statesman the Hamilton fish so that's up
that's the first doomsday device on him
like not really set him up for disaster
being named after a statesman and his
father was [__] 43 years older than
his mother I mean that is some Tom
Cruise Katie Holmes [__] okay so that's
more disaster okay he had the recipient
yang his child and that's not so good
one child [__] named Albert died so he
took his name he's like [__] it I'm
gonna take it okay
can i [__] up oh actually it was
supposed to the fort sibling so there's
three other siblings not a fourth one
the fourth one died and he he just had
like [__] it I'm gonna I'm gonna take
take his name okay now can I really
[__] up but he changed he also got you
know made fun of at school to call him
ham and eggs that's another reason
another trigger I guess it just triggers
galore with this guy okay
his family had mental illness his uncle
had mania his brother was confined in
that mental hospital his sister even had
a mental affliction but they didn't
actually know what it was back then my
three of relatives had mental illnesses
and the mother had [__] like
schizophrenia okay I know lots of cheer
lots of chairs so his father died and
then his mother decided like bucket like
this kid is talking like a lone ma let's
put him in an orphanage okay and they
treated him even worse they're like they
they beat the [__] out of him and just
like whip them and he actually started
to enjoy the physical pain that the
beatings brought it's kind of it's
really [__] up and he was saying her
ripped all time and he saw a lot of
things that you know people shouldn't be
doing you know and so the mother
actually you know got a little more
settled in you know later on in life I
was able to take him out of the
orphanage but in its kind of [__] up
so okay here's an extra girl he actually
had a relationship at age 12 for the
Telegraph boy one of those like a phone
operator guys kind of [__] up and this
guy I don't mean I mean fish knows had a
pic of this guy he loved jerking urine
and eating [__] like literally eating
[__] he said [__] like he liked the
dribble and hassles and shed so then he
introduces fish to this and fish was
like well like yeah this is great like
you know like I like this and so he
would go to like the public bathroom was
and watch like boys on your ass and
watch him make me love poopies and [__]
very [__] up very [__] up and then
he would like also like will watch
people and
he would get like endeared to people too
so he would look in the newspaper and
every time if you had found like names
he would like good right there like
obscene letters like it's really [__]
up okay so okay let's fast forward in
like ten years or so he's in New York
setting fish he became a prostitute sort
of raping young boys really [__] up
the mother actually arranged of marriage
with them that was like nine years
younger I think the kid was like twenty
this time so the kid was like the girl
was like [__] eleven but he had
[__] six kids with this this guy they
[__] up then I think um almost ten
years later he worked as a house painter
he started molesting [__] kids kids
are [__] younger than six it really
[__] up so he went to a max max Museum
inside like in love with like the penis
being split apart after that he became
with like sexual mutilation he got
arrested though for like grand larceny
and went to jail anyway
so you know he gets out though okay
about like ten years later and this
guy's stuff really [__] up and he's
just trying to really [__] with people
so we came back and he started to like
up getting people he got like
intellectually disabled guys are like
torturing him cut off his penis and it's
it's insane he poured like I think he
comes like guy's penis and started just
like [__] with it and he like [__]
him up gave him money like left it was
[__] weird it was like a really weird
guy and then his wife left him and so
this guy
I think Fisher never got a joke for this
until I go later but Fisher's wife left
him and then fish was like huh yeah like
I gotta raise all these kids as a single
my [__] six kids he apparently
started going nuts you know he started
going [__] like crazy like what you
know his mother with hallucinations
schizophrenia really came back and he
really believe he's doing like God's
work and [__] like that
so she would start like [__]
hurt himself so you put a [__] ton of
needles in him so big this picture here
[__] up needles all over he just liked
[__] with it was like pelvis and he
would also use an else thought at paddle
too [__] abused himself and then he
would sometimes [__] start doing like
cannibalism this was when he started
getting real into camp lism and he would
prepare himself like human meat and also
beat his [__] kids made it really
[__] up bunny love this kid he loved
his kid we started going crazy another
teen years passed and he is like
stabbing like mentally handicapped
people he loved men to handicap or
african-americans because he said like
nobody would look for them though he had
these things called implements of hell
you know it's a meat cleaver butcher
knife and a small handsaw no I had she
was hanging a rough but okay
anyway he you know be he got kind of
caught a couple times like not really in
an act but just like being creepy
there's an incident when he was like
following some chick and once like play
but then the mother came I was like well
why did he done with my daughter and
like he ran away but [__] like slept
and hid their barn and then he got
caught again he [__] up Danny got
crazy and crazy he also started like
[__] well a little side dice also did
bigamy he started like marrying someone
else when it was still married [__]
weird
he and eventually it all kind of went to
his capture and grace bud to heat this
girl he's a picture here took this girl
[__] just like I think he was like
entrapping her or something
I think he like played with her and like
something about like when she was
sitting on his lap he was like oh man
I'm at this girl's great I'm gonna get
her you know so apparently what he did
was he not only after he did this he
[__] wrote a letter to the girl's
parents
was laid just like it was [__] up and
it was just basically detailed how the
[__] went down and the mother was
illiterate so kind of read it what son
of a [__] every day and it's basically
that how like what he did was he invited
her over or brought her the house and he
totally outside he went inside got naked
and then when she came in he like popped
out of the mirrors and like scared the
[__] over on the knee got her and like
[__] ate her and then he like just
[__] up anyway the letter had like a
we're we're like LM on it basically like
the people have delivered it like check
the back down to him and they [__] got
it
they [__] got it and they pleaded it
he actually pleaded insanity
psychiatrist [__] like burn about all
the [__] [__] it was like they they
never had like someone so locked up
they're like this guy is crazy okay
and I only tell you it was basically
pretty easy for him to [__] planet
insanity but they actually like they all
George believed he was insane but they
actually just wanted to [__] and kill
him anyway because they fought him he
was really crazy
so they actually found him to be sane so
they actually send a cadet incentives
they kind of found this out later yeah
yeah yeah so basically anyway there was
like a final statement that he wrote and
they like released later and they said
like they would never showed anyone
because it was like I think it was quote
saying something like it was the most
filthy like sentence of obscenities that
he's ever read and you know the like
lawyer would never [__] ever show
anyone so anyway that's this dude very
[__] up very [__] up bowler cap
mustache last name fish I mean this guy
is just chars galore just triggers
galore I was like
[__] up anyways if you like this
series I'm gonna keep it going you know
that may be called something something
silly like Psychopaths but I know y'all
people like me and God Psychopaths so I
don't know after they're here I don't
know I don't know help God good
all right I'm gonna go I guess I'm gonna
head of this film and [__] eat a
cheeseburger until next time thank ya